that's the sound of a cleaner start
adult taxi now runs on Iraqi produced
liquefied petroleum gas or LPG his daily
fuel cost is nearly a third of what he
used to pay for regular petrol for sure
it is more economical and hence more
profitable instead of paying 16 dollars
per day for fuel now I pay a run six
dollars it's mandatory for new public
transport vehicles to install LPG kits
although the law was passed in 2016 it
was only implemented a year ago the oil
ministry is subsidizing the installation
instead of a thousand dollars it costs
around four hundred dollars to install
an LPG kit a miss any new project faces
resistance the oil ministry has tried to
tell people that there is no danger as
the cylinder doesn't explode the kits
are safe and with international
standards the gasket is safe and
complies with international standards
there is propaganda to defame the
ministry's efforts it just needs some
time so people start to understand the
benefits of LPG there are up to six
million cars in the Iraqi capital more
than 500 are registered every month with
no new roads of reges 3000 officers and
600 cameras still contraband gridlock
the traffic department is encouraging
the use of alternative fuel Swifties
Baghdad's public transport spews fewer
emissions we have installed gaskets on
different types of vehicles there have
been no accidents or explosions through
word of mouth other drivers are also
beginning to see the benefits
that's the case among many drivers who
started using gas-powered taxis yes of
course I encourage all drivers to
install it it's safe and nothing wrong
will happen people say it's not safe to
use the gasket I have witnessed two
incidents with friends cars who did not
have the kit their fuel tank caught fire
because of loose wires in the fuel pump
your out is the second largest producer
among oil-producing OPEC nations and is
trying to reduce its gas flare at
refineries much of Ralphs liquefied
petroleum gas is a readily available
by-product the pilot phase in public
transport is meant to reduce the carbon
footprint and expensive refined fuel
imports the government plans to expand
it to hospitals restaurants and even
homes but it still needs to convince
Iraqis that it is a safer cheaper and
cleaner alternative some of the Javad
others era Baghdad